(whimsical music)
- Walter, Pepper and Chili.
Louvinia, Billy Idol, Lil'
Hootie, Stevie Wonder,
Opus, Lolly, Top Hat.
Right now I think I have about 36 turtles.
I'm Lorri Cramer, I'm the
turtle lady of Manhattan.
I'm the only wildlife
rehabilitator in the city
that works just specifically with turtles.
I rehab turtles in an
apartment in New York City.
Bringing turtles into
the country illegally,
has become big business.
I get turtles from the Department
of Environmental Conservation,
U.S. Fish and Wildlife,
the urban park rangers, even by policemen.
Last summer I had 680 baby
turtles that were brought
here from the Department of
Environmental Conservation.
It's overwhelming to have
a large amount of turtles
in a New York City apartment.
I've promised my husband a bathroom
and a bedroom without turtles.
The back bathroom is
where we take our showers,
and it's a people bathroom. (laughs)
If I lived outside the
city and I had a yard,
I probably would be rehabilitating
all kinds of wild animals.
But here in Manhattan,
turtles are perfect.
When I was a child there was no place
for women in vet school.
But somehow things come full circle.
I'm a turtle nurse, that's basically it.
I think that I’ll get good
turtle points in Heaven.
(whimsical music)